eu trouxe uma palavra que eu amo pra
começar nossa
à noite desra option tem tradução de
água português disrupção rompimento a
palavra sobre moderno lembra gente está
a tap economia criativa mas é uma
palavra que até pouco tempo é na nossa
história ela não era tão bem vista em
dois fatos importantes e tive a ditadura
militar e em novembro em outubro de de
73 em cinco meses nós tivemos 400 por
cento de inflação no petróleo começava a
crise do petróleo
falar em juízo pensão no brasil do
período militar
era quase uma subversão até hoje eu falo
com minha mãe mãe trabalha com diop é
meu deus meu filho mas isso dá cadeia
não se preocupa ea velocidade que isso
acontece hoje incomoda muita gente
principalmente das gerações antigas onde
entrar no tema específico eu queria
convidar vocês uma viagem muito rápido
imagina se a gente pudesse ouvir a nossa
o nosso planeta respirar e crescer
a terra tem 4.5 bilhões de anos e
demorou 1 bilhão de anos pelo que se
imaginou que um bilhão de reais mas não
um bilhão de anos até à primeira forma
de vida na terra
depois de mais três pontos 3 bilhões de
anos para nós seres humanos começarmos a
nos desenvolvermos a terra ou seja nós
estamos aqui há 200 mil anos 0.00 5% do
tempo da terra e houve até hoje uma
grande opção uma grande ruptura
fomos nós nós somos a verdadeira diz
robinson que aconteceu na terra e não só
isso
nos últimos 100 anos de 1916 a 2016
nós colocamos quase 6 bilhões de pessoas
na terra
inúmeros pequenos 154 mil pessoas
nasceram estão nascendo por dia e claro
isso traz um problema sério para o nosso
modo de vida nos últimos cem anos tudo
mudou
o mundo começou a se tornar um pano e
nós estamos prevendo entre 2015 ano
passado e 2020 uma migração urbana
diária de 370 mil pessoas saindo às suas
cidades do interior pra trás grandes
capitais
o brasil está muito urbano mas vai para
a índia por exemplo a 39% somente dia d
de taxa de urbanização os próximos 30
anos 300 milhões de pessoas vão migrar
do interior da índia para as grandes
cidades para ficar fácil de entender
isso de novo número pequeno lagos na
nigéria ano passado recebeu 85 pessoas
por dia são paulo 18 pessoas desculpa
por hora
dezoito pessoas ano passado chegaram a
cada hora 365 dias por ano aqui o são
paulo por esse fluxo de pessoas acaba
agravando muitos problemas que a gente
já tinha necessidade de soluções para
estes problemas já nascem pagas por si
só pela solução que ela traz os estados
unidos chama se nós gastamos perdemos
jogamos fora 121 bilhões de dólares por
ano um trânsito e no número ainda é um
pouco pior
uma é a pesquisa no passado revelou que
aproximadamente 95% da população mundial
7 bilhões de pessoas têm pelo menos um
tipo de doença
eu cheguei hoje os números que estão que
estão disponíveis
este ano já morreram 46 milhões de
pessoas
outras 46 milhões pessoas 6 milhões eram
crianças mas 12%
nossas crianças não só estão morrendo
mas também essas crianças não estão se
preparando o futuro
segundo a unesco o ano passado 57
milhões de crianças estão fora da escola
e não dá mais para pensar e resolver os
problemas de forma linear de forma
matricial a nossa matriz está errada eu
tenho está fazendo 100 mil escolas esse
ano eu tenho vontade política eu
provavelmente não tem dinheiro
direcionado
isso não significa dizer que tem uma
escola e uma criança estudando em roupa
interior da amazônia eu não consigo
colocar eu tenho crianças espalhadas que
eu não consigo colocar uma escola para
cada criança do filho de escola onde
quiser mudar a maneira que a gente pensa
ea maneira que a gente formata o nosso
estilo de vida
a pergunta é o que está sendo feito
desde a década de 90 e de 80 nos estados
unidos principalmente por esse problema
de imigração começa a se falar de
cidades inteligentes e cidade
inteligente é o conceito de cidade
inteligente ele vem evoluindo em todo
esse processo de junção então nos
últimos 30 anos
um conceito que era simplesmente
tecnológico ele passa a ter uma outras
variáveis que são fundamentos
fundamentais não só para entender esse
conceito mas não colocar em prática está
fazendo doutorado agora sociedade
inteligente eu não é definir ainda há o
meu conceito de cidade inteligente mas
ele vai ter pelo menos cinco elementos
primeiro é assim tecnologia não só
tecnologia como da comunicação da
informação mas principalmente hoje
chamada internet de tudo que a evolução
da internet das coisas que está
começando a falar agora
depois projeto tem se orientado ao
cidadão na década de 80 tecnologia pela
tecnologia hoje a gente tem que resolver
o problema com o cidadão tem aplicando a
tecnologia terceiro tempo bom tem que
focar em melhorar a qualidade de vida
das pessoas
e aí todos esses três pilares da cidade
inteligente eles têm que hoje é é serem
considerados sobre os objectivos as
novas economias chrome criativa economia
compartilhada cocriação economia
circular e tem que trazer resiliência
para a cidade
lembre se tem um problema de imigração
não só as cidades grandes ou sofrendo
problemas mas nos estados unidos na
europa tem cidades fantasmas da
inteligente pode ser aplicado está
fazendo agora na cidade como na itália 4
mil habitantes só está levando consigo
as cidades inteligentes e pergunta é
porque nós precisamos estudar
inteligente
parece que está muito claro todo esse
problema que é gerado é em função da
migração mas a grande verdade é a junção
somos nós
dizem eles
estão sendo desenvolvidas porque a
sociedade está ficando mais inteligente
os chamados milênios já tem uma
perspectiva de vida completamente
diferente da minha geração que a geração
x
eles são conectados eles querem cocriar
ele está fazendo essa nova economia e
eles querem essa nova como economia não
só no setor privado na vida profissional
mas também na na na relação deles com o
9º sentimento de cidadão desenvolveram
uma teoria do meu doutorado chamados
matar eu coloco juntos max diz que o
conceito de novo já tem 30 anos com
startup que é o conceito da da criação
de ideias sob uma nova perspectiva
econômica e aí nasce o conceito ismar
tato mas consciente de matar pieu eu dou
quatro dicas e aí eu sempre com
prefeitos e com um é desenvolvido na
edição hoje de 76 ers
as pessoas estão fazendo as cidades eu
dou quatro dicas de como acelerar o
processo de mudança do estilo de vida
urbano que nós temos
a primeira dica as pessoas não querem
uma cidade nova as pessoas querem uma
cidade melhor
toda a cidade tem dna você se você quer
de são paulo se consiga se identifica
não com seu país mas com sua cidade você
é paulistano tanto é que tem uma briga
enorme rio são paulo porque nós nos
identificamos o a-ha a entidade é é
governo é governamental para a gente ou
alguém se sente cidadão ea nossa cidade
dica número um resumo dna da sua cidade
em uma apresentação de elevador de cinco
minutos num modelo storytelling
a gente precisa vender à sociedade por
nosso cidadão ele precisa vender a
cidade para os investidores querem pela
cidade
eu tive no passado o rio de janeiro é a
cidade mais inteligente do do brasil sob
o ponto de vista de um ranking do ano
passado ninguém no rio de janeiro
considera morando na cidade inteligente
eu tive santiago do chile tendo uma
palestra ano passado mesmo perguntar com
o prefeito de santiago
estou muito honrado está aqui a cidade
mais inteligente da américa latina e
passa o rio vem morar aqui perceber como
é que tem gente que o prefeito com a
cara do meu lado
moral da história com o prefeito
pergunta tenho a cidade inteligente
tanto o cidadão cidade inteligente um
estilo de vida
percepção eu preciso perceber que tudo
aquilo que está ao meu redor está
conspirando para ter uma qualidade de
vida melhor
segundo simplicidade espera o momento
certo e investir em projetos milionários
que provavelmente você não tem dinheiro
pra fazer isso eu vejo os prefeitos com
quando chego um manual técnico de 200
pais daquelas peças é inteligente atrair
a focar em que a nós vamos fazer um
centro de orações controle
o problema é que a cidade tem relevância
inteligente pra minha cidade na itália
um projeto da rússia de moscou e cortava
discutindo com eles o case bufando foi a
transferir pessoal 64 bits
meu problema é que tem javali na cidade
que invade a produção de uva como uva há
40 anos atrás
os caçadores levaram javalis capacidade
para caçar agora não pode mais passar já
vai se multiplicar e agora foi um
problema eu tenho que usar tecnologia
para resolver esse problema da minha
cidade não por trânsito que não tem nem
como nem com o sinal vermelho é fecha eu
tem trânsito na cidade
3º parcerias se entender que é um
conjunto de stakeholders de interessados
que fazem uma cidade melhor
o governo é importantíssimo como aquele
que que liga as pontas mas cidade é
inteligente precisa ser feita por um
conjunto de academia universidade é é
setor privado e setor público e cidadão
sociedade organizada e por último se
fala muito do instrumento e é um
instrumento hoje mais é é é eficiente
para fazer cidade inteligente no mundo
de ppp parceria público privada que está
desenvolvendo hoje um conceito novo de
ppp parceria público privado com pessoas
de novo as pessoas precisam ser parte do
processo de solução da sociedade e essa
nova essa nova geração que parece que tá
longe milênio em 2020 e 49% por dadá dos
trabalhadores mundiais da força de
trabalho serão milênio esses caras estão
prontos para fazer a compilação eu falar
que em dois sentidos
eu posso trazer o cidadão para co criar
e resolver os problemas dele e também
hoje a super moda que não falem porque
eu não gosto mesmo
o cidadão queria muito investir numa
empresa que está investindo para fazer a
cidade melhor para minha cidade em dobro
do dinheiro não há já paga imposto pra
isso taxa mas eu quero virar sócio
imagina se alguém tivesse convidado que
fazer caldo falando em do facebook ou do
ou doar bing ou do uber todos eles são
soluções urbanas problemas urbanos que
nós temos
eu trouxe dois casos daqui e de cidades
inteligentes que mudar um pouquinho
perspectiva e que é a nova tendência
primeiro rio de janeiro e acompanha o
processo da preparação do rio de janeiro
para as olimpíadas eo bm foi o rio de
janeiro vamos fazer o estado da arte o
maior o maior e mais moderno centro de
operações e controle do mundo bacana
cinco meses de janeiro levantou uma
estrutura foi o projeto mais rápido da
ibm na hora de ligar o botão para
funcionar agora vamos controlar o
trânsito porque vai ter vento e tal
ele conta que mais se tem 800 de
brincadeira janeiro oito celas
londres tem 16 mil câmeras
moscou tem 140 mil campo como na cidade
inteligente com com 16 é com 800 câmeras
só para duplicar para votar 1600 câmeras
gera mais caros em operações de controle
o chefe da oficina de janeiro pegou um
avião para san francisco começar com uma
empresa que estava indo pro aip ou
chamado gleise oeste já ele estava já no
vale do silício falou que vem nós temos
em um milhão de usuários no rio de
janeiro vêm pra cá abri dados com a
gente vão criar uma plataforma onde
antigos a tua informação pra proteger a
informação de inteligência para a cidade
o e foi o enredo xuxa ganha-ganha o rio
pagou nada hoje não pagou nada com isso
conseguiu criar um algoritmo de todas
essas informações e manda foto do
acidente que a gente faz aqui em são
paulo no esse ano já nessa foto vai
apresentar ações de controle do dia pra
noite passou de 800 câmeras mais de um
milhão de usuários com criando o
processo de de fazer cidade inteligente
segundo o segundo o segundo case moscou
moscou a gente tem aquela visão que
burocracia de fé de comunismo e tal eu
estou agora dando dando consultoria para
o governo de moscou por uma cidade
inteligente moscou ganhou esse
ano ficou classificado com a segunda
cidade mais orientada dados do mundo
tudo em moscou hoje digital eu quero
marcar uma consulta com o médico tem o
hospital tem um médico mas eu faço isso
online
e aí o sistema otimiza todo o sistema de
moscou ontem de 12 milhões de habitantes
e mais oito que como tão renato seguinte
se você quiser fazendo toda a tua no seu
centro de saúde no seu posto de saúde
daqui a dois meses tem vaga
agora se você quiser fazer até 2 horas
há dois bairros adiante tem um posto de
saúde livre com horário livre
está tudo aí não precisa inventar a roda
os dados já estão abertos os dados já
estão sendo captados eu só preciso
conectar isso de forma inteligente bem
como a teoria de doutorado e tentando
provar é que isso deve inteligentes
podem ser verdadeiros laboratórios para
desenvolver testar e aperfeiçoar os
novos modelos de vida eu acredito muito
nisso e acredito que ele possa fazer
isso aqui também no brasil
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]